sortir entre amis au restaurant simple
plaisir retrouvé les groupes de cinq
personnes sont permis depuis lundi
dernier à singapour auparavant le
maximum était de deux personnes
la récente flambée de kobe 19 après un
premier relâchement des mesures
sanitaires s'essouffle on dénombre moins
de 2000 cas par jour après avoir atteint
un sommet de cinq mille ans le petit
pays de moins de 6 millions d'habitants
dans cette clinique médicale comme
partout à singapour le même constat la
quasi totalité des personnes déclarées
positives ne présente que des symptômes
légers bonino ce prof
oui
comme le nez qui coule un mal de gorge
ou une faible fièvre
le taux de vaccination parmi les plus
élevés de la planète expliquerait cette
réalité
94% des singapouriens admissibles sont
pleinement vacciner le cas ont même déjà
reçu une dose de rappel
cette immunisation inciter le
gouvernement à changer de stratégie
l'été dernier ajoute ce spécialiste
fini l'objectif coved 0 singapour a été
un des premiers pays à annoncer qu'il
allait apprendre à vivre avec le virus
c'est une phase de transition pour
sortir de la pandémie explique t-il
singapour ira même plus loin pour forcer
ses citoyens à se faire immuniser dans
deux semaines tout personnes non
vaccinées qui contractent le virus devra
payer elle-même pour ses soins et ses
frais d'hospitalisation saw 6 pc r
notre
action
une mesure somme toute bien accueillie
par la majorité
c'est préférable que tout le monde soit
vacciné croit cet homme qui a vu
plusieurs personnes autrefois
anti-vaccins changé d'opinion en raison
des mesures gouvernementales coercitives
bon nombre de ces mesures demeurent
d'ailleurs en vigueur le masque est
obligatoire partout l'application de
géolocalisation ne permet qu'aux
personnes vaccinées d'entrer dans les
édifices publics
jong jong n'a perdu 40% de son chiffre
d'affaires durant la pandémie elle ne
peut accueillir que 15 clients à la fois
dans sa boutique elle sent que les
mesures sanitaires exaspère de plus en
plus les singapouriens je pense pas que
les gens qui pour vivre encore plus avec
tout le traitement et le mesure
stoïquement je pense et des papes pour
le business signé le mentalité des gens
nous ont
dit à singapour qu'on apprend à vivre
avec l'aco vide mais le long combat pour
retrouver une vie normale ne fait que
commencer ici philippe leblanc radio
canada singapour